[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
it's johnny depp versus amber heard how
herd's sister describes a tense incident
between the couple he strikes me in the
back i hear amber shout don't hit my
sister there's broken glass like it just
the place was destroyed
and those closest to her describe her
relationship with death were you afraid
that mr depp was going to hurt miss
heard
yes
plus the murder of a florida state
university professor charlie adelson's
family had a big problem and that
problem was dan markell this defendant
was the solution if she did not know
she is not guilty on all three counts
it's that simple hear from both sides in
the retrial of catherine meg badwa and
later the cross-examination of defendant
ryan duke when you walked in the police
department that morning you were
prepared to confess correct
i was prepared to take the blame for
something i didn't do why he says a
childhood best friend is to blame for
the murder of tara grinstead law and
crime daily covering court cases from
coast to coast
welcome everybody to law and crime daily
i'm brian ross in today for brian
buckmeyer well we've heard from amber
heard now we're hearing from her sister
who testified about johnny depp and
heard's marriage
long crimes angenette levy is here with
testimony of whitney enriquez
angeannette
well brian whitney henriquez was the
only person the only witness to testify
in person today she testified that
johnny depp was intelligent kind and
charming when he wasn't abusing drugs
but enriquez told the jury that when
depp was using drugs or using alcohol
his behavior changed enriquez said that
she had used cocaine with depp several
times and she said she she actually
liked him quite a lot he called her sis
and she referred to him as brother she
also recalled an incident on a plane
ride to london where she said that
johnny depp threw a knife at his
assistant then she discussed that march
2015 incident at the penthouse where
amber heard said she had punched johnny
depp
to protect whitney
he comes up behind me
strikes me in the back
kind of just somewhere over here he
strikes me in the back i hear amber
shout don't hit my sister
she smacks him lands one and then he
grabs at that point that's when travis
runs up the stairs after amber landed
one and but by that time johnny had
already grabbed the ember by the hair
with one hand and was whacking her
repeatedly in the face with the other
as i was standing there travis pulls
them apart i get amber into mine i close
the doors behind me and lock them
i then hear johnny's voice shouting
i hear johnny's voice shouting you i
hate you i hate you both you
fucking whores
and i hear crashing i hear crashing and
banging and smashing and he starts
screaming like an animal
and
i then just moved amber into the next
room and i just kept her there all night
the next day i go and i see her closet
has been completely destroyed
and we actually saw a photo of amber
heard's closet room that she said that
johnny depp destroyed on that night he
had knocked apparently clothing racks
over you may recall that travis mcgivern
that bodyguard of johnny depps who was
there testified that depp rearranged her
closet we saw the pictures today and
amber heard had testified you'll recall
that that fight started that time in
march of 2015 she claims that she found
text messages on johnny depp's ipad when
he was sleeping and they were between
him and a woman with whom he had been
intimate in the past and so that is why
the argument started brian and jeanette
do you think whitney enrique's testimony
accomplished what amber herd's lawyers
hoped it would did it help her hurt her
sister
you know it it's all going to be up to
the jury but she backed up her sister's
story about the staircase incident
obviously you know johnny depp contends
he's never hit a woman didn't hit
whitney hurd or amber heard whitney her
whitney enriquez is contradicting that
and saying
that he did hit her in the back and that
he hit uh then that he had hit amber
heard
so it doesn't sound like she had ever
witnessed that the the the physical
abuse but she's recal calling and
recounting this evening that sounded
pretty volatile that's when the
bodyguard travis mcgivern said he wanted
to get johnny depp out of there
because it was just getting to be too
heated
angela let me ask you something that
came up during cross-examination depp's
lawyer asked henriquez about a woman
named jennifer hall and her relationship
with her how is that relevant
you know it's very interesting that that
was brought up on cross-examination
brian and they went up to the judge to
have a sidebar about this issue and when
the lawyer came back she asked her about
jennifer howe and the fact that she had
referred to jennifer howe as her chosen
sister she had actually lived with
jennifer howell for a time as well and
worked for her jennifer howe filed a
document with the court and in that
document we didn't hear about the
document or her claims but in that
document she said that she disputes
whitney herd's account she says that
whitney heard
loved johnny depp and that she said that
amber heard was the abuser in the
relationship and she didn't understand
why johnny depp was staying and she said
that when she found out about the
australia incident and johnny depp's
finger being cut off this jennifer house
quotes
amber heard sister as saying now she's
done it using an expletive she cut his
finger off
the twists and turns art engine to stay
there still ahead on law and crime daily
our comprehensive coverage of the johnny
depp amber heard trial continues
still ahead hear from those who lived in
depp's penthouse alongside amber what
acts of violence they say occurred in
front of them
[Music]
welcome back we continue our coverage
now in the johnny depp amber herd
defamation trial on wednesday jurors
watched the video deposition of raquel
pennington heard's best friend who lived
with her in the eastern columbia
building pennington testified she took
photos of her that depicted injuries to
her face
i was scared for amber
i was sad for her and i was also sad for
johnny
because she is my friend too
i really wanted them to be able to
get it together
why were you scared for amber
i'm gonna be very unpredictable
of amber's face
with two black
eyes and swollen bottom lip
later jurors heard the deposition
testimony of joshua drew pennington's
ex-husband and a friend of herds he says
heard was catatonic when police arrived
after a fight with depp
i was outside the door with the mail
officer
and
specifically my communication with him
was
asking what if anything could be done
because we were obviously upset and his
comment to me specifically was there's
damage in these apartments her face is
red if she wants to file a report we
have enough here to go pick him up
amber was
near catatonic after all this we had
gotten her into ph 1 so we could
deadbolt the door and keep her safe
until he left
we're joined today by criminal defense
attorney michael brechner co-host terry
austin and correspondent angenette levy
michael let me start with you joshua
drew told attorneys he never saw depp
physically hit her but saw the fallout
of intense arguments multiple times does
that add up to he heard and saw amber
heard get hurt
oftentimes lawyers only have what we
call circumstantial evidence to
corroborate the testimony of other
people and some of this testimony can be
very helpful for a person who says look
i didn't see the event but this is
the circumstances that i did witness i
saw the catatonic state of amber um i
saw and heard noises i heard the
screaming this is all also corroborative
of the testimony of the witnesses and
can be very helpful for um for a jury is
trying to determine whether an event
occurred so it's not unusual to have a
witness like this testify um about the
the circumstances even though he may not
have seen the actual alleged assault
terry austin let me ask you rachel
pennington was a racquel pennington was
amber's best friend of the time now they
don't speak to each other
what does that mean do you think for the
jurors
you know i think it's going to be a
little confusing for the jury generally
speaking when you have someone who's
very close to this witness you're going
to think that they are biased in favor
of the party but here she's saying she
hasn't spoken to amber in six months she
said they are not enemies she said they
grew apart but you know she didn't
classify them as friends either and so i
think what the jury is going to do is
listen to what she has to say maybe
she's neutral i will say though brian at
the end of the day much of her testimony
had to do with injuries that she said
she thought depp had inflicted upon
amber so she overall was in favor of
amber
anjanette you're in the courtroom video
depositions as you know are often less
exciting than seeing an actual witness
in the courtroom how are jurors reacting
now to these many videos being shown
and it's really interesting brian
because wednesday all we saw were video
depositions with the exception of windy
whitney enriquez they're watching
they're taking notes you know they have
breaks throughout the day
but they they're just paying attention
and i see poker faces really i don't see
much expression i did see one woman
juror or female
smile today and they smiled when they
were greeted by the judge but they're
not really showing a lot of reaction to
the video depositions all right anjanet
michael and terry thank you very much
coming up on law and crime daily juror
is here opening statements in the case
of catherine mcbogma a woman allegedly
involved in a florida murder for hire
plot
plus jurors hear from co-defendants in
the tara grinstein trial in georgia
one of them doesn't tell his side of the
story
[Music]
and welcome back prosecutors argue key
pieces of evidence point to kathryn
mcbonwall his opening statements are
presented in her retrial where she is
accused of being the go-between in the
murder-for-hire plot of a florida state
university professor
dan markell was shot and killed in 2014
at the time he and his wife wendy
adelson were in a custody battle
prosecutors say wendy's brother charles
adelson recruited his then-girlfriend
catherine beg benoit to help murder
markell
mcbenoir contacted the father of her
children six fredo garcia who later
enlisted a second person louise rivera
officials say garcia and rivera then
shot and killed markel in 2019 garcia
and meg benoit were tried as
co-defendants garcia was convicted and
given life in prison without parole but
the jury was unable to reach a verdict
for meg benoit last month charlie
anderson was arrested and charged with
first-degree murder conspiracy to commit
murder and solicitation to murder meg
bangla faces the same three charges now
prosecutors presented their case before
the jury for the first time on wednesday
the reason we're here this morning is
because the defendant in this case
catherine magmanwa
set up the murder of a man named dan
markell
and the evidence in this case will prove
to you
that the defendant was the link
or the middleman the defendant had a
rich boyfriend named charlie adelson
and charlie adelson's family had a big
problem and that problem was dan markell
this defendant was the solution
because she had connections to the type
of people who were willing and capable
of pointing a gun
at a stranger someone they'd never met
and pulling the trigger
meg benoit's defense attorney told
jurors their decision at the end of the
trial should be easy after the evidence
is presented
the state and i can actually agree on
two very important points about this
case
number one
charles adelson had dan markel killed we
absolutely agree with that
number two
luis rivero and sigfrato garcia
carried out the hit for charlie adelson
what we do not agree on is whether or
not catherine mcbanwa
knew about a plan to have dan markel
killed
the only question that you are all going
to have to answer at the end of all of
this evidence is
did catherine know
that's it it's that simple
if she did not know
she is not guilty on all three counts
michael beckner meg benoit's
co-defendant was found guilty and her
ex-boyfriend now also faces charges in
connection to markelle's murder it
doesn't bode well for her does it
well the fact of their
convictions uh is not admissible
evidence at her trial
uh unless these individuals end up being
witnesses and then they can be
cross-examined about it but
the jury is going to be asked to
determine the culpability of this
defendant alone the lawyer is going to
do her job i'm assuming and advise the
jury that their focus is only on her and
only on her evidence and we do know
there was a hung jury the first time so
at least some jurors had issues with the
proof
uh and uh i guess we're gonna have to
wait we're gonna wait and see the fact
that two people were convicted uh does
not mean that uh miss uh baguata is
going to uh suffer the same result but
uh we'll have to wait and see
darius michael says the jury could not
reach a unanimous decision last time so
with a retrial does the prosecution
stand a better chance of getting a
conviction
i definitely think the prosecution has a
better chance i mean you can argue that
the defense does as well but i think
that the prosecution now knows the
strengths and weaknesses of their case
and they're going to try to strengthen
that connection that benoit has to the
crime they're going to focus on hard
evidence like phone records and the
other thing working to their advantage
is now that charlie adelson has been
arrested he could very well take a plea
d and point the finger at mcmahon and i
think that's exactly what he will do and
i think if they do that then they're
going to be able to tie banoi to all of
the other individuals had it not been
for her this would not have occurred all
right terry and michael thanks much when
we come back co-defendants take the
stand in a georgia cobra ryan duke tells
his side of the story pointing the
finger at beau dukes on how former
beauty queen tara princeton was murdered
[Music]
welcome back co-defendants ryan duke and
bo dukes take the stand in a georgia
courtroom
as dukes fakes a murder charge for the
death of georgia teacher and beauty
queen tara grinstead nearly 17 years
after her disappearance
ryan duke and bo dukes were friends and
classmates at the time of grinston's
disappearance the former beauty queen
went missing from her georgia home in
october of 2005. for years investigators
had very few leads and the case
seemingly went cold then in 2017 after a
podcast renewed interest in the case
duke and dukes were arrested prosecutors
say ryan duke told police he broke into
greenson's home and killed her they
argue bo dukes helped duke burn her body
while on the stand tuesday ryan duke
told a different story that beau killed
greenstead and that he was the one who
helped cover it up on cross-examination
duke was questioned about his interview
with police where he confessed to
grinstead's death
you told agent chadell that you hit her
correct
yes ma'am i told him that and you're now
saying that was a lie yes ma'am and
you've already told this jury that
you're claiming you don't know how she
died correct i don't when you walked in
the police department that morning you
were prepared to confess correct
i was prepared to take the blame for
something i didn't do
but you were there because you've
already admitted you helped put her
lifeless body on top of that fire pit
yes ma'am i did
and you don't want to admit having seen
the match struck but you know that she
was set on fire
yes ma'am
and you knew that on october 23rd of
2005.
yes ma'am and you knew that on october
24th of 2005. yes ma'am and you knew
that on october 25th of 2005 and every
day after that's right every day after
and you never told a song
shortly after the testimony of ryan duke
ended his defense called bo dukes to the
stand
in the ambassador council i'll be
invoking my fifth amendment right not to
provide testimony
um
how did you get here today
on the advice of council i'll be working
my fifth number right not to provide
testimony today mr dude do you intend to
invoke
your fifth amendment right to every
question i do your own
[Applause]
the michael bachner ryan duke's tape
confession seemed to be fairly
convincing do you think his testimony on
the stand convinced the jury that it was
a false confession
well he seems very well prepared he's
trying to keep his demeanor and his calm
but at the end of the day it's a very
hard
pull to make for a jury that you decided
to go into a police
station and admit that you kept you
committed a capital offense and oops i
was just kidding um or i was nervous i
was or i was scared and uh and
incriminated myself in that in that type
of a fashion uh because i was either
concerned about the duke family beau's
family or whatever it might be uh that's
a very hard argument to make people uh i
think a jury's gonna have a very hard
time acknowledging the fact or accepting
the fact that he just voluntarily
incriminated himself in a capital
offense uh it's it's a very hard but
it's his only out he has to say he uh he
lied about it because uh what's his
option that's what he's got right so
terry beaudrucks got on the witness
stand but then he invoked his fifth
amendment right not to testify against
himself how do you think that affects
the case against ryan duke
listen i think beau duke's refusal to
speak is definitely going to help ryan
duke there's no question about it you
have a constitutional right against
self-incrimination and the judge will
allow that even though he got up on the
stand and said he didn't want to talk it
seems like a waste of time but i think
that he is doing it strategically
because he doesn't want to get more time
and a jury is definitely going to use
that against him and let it look
favorably upon ryan duke so i think at
the end of the day it helps ryan
all right terry austin michael bachner
thank you so much and thank you for
joining us here on law and crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you